oh no that's off one of them is off
Nina's first learning there it is your
one word super exciting oh yeah that's
smells like victory what's up everyone
we're super excited it is what time is
it for us is midnight on the Thursday
now and excited because my book arrived
these are the galley copies the advanced
Galilee copies make sure the first ever
printed version of my book and I wanted
to wait because I have a bunch of other
packages I was into a male time I want
the way to open it and he's like no it's
exciting we gonna win it right now this
is maybe like anything she tell you but
you had this huge smile on her face and
the smile always melts me she's very
excited I'm excited teen with me as more
excited so so we're gonna open it
because Nina really wants to okay so
here we go this is the first printed
copy of my book
oh this deal oh they put it in bubble
paper everything oh wow oh this is a
soft cover it's not the hardcover yeah
that's good thanks hello this looks so
small there it is your one word super
exciting this is nice listen let me
smell the paper okay I likes how in the
paper look at this look how easy this is
to read this is pretty special I want a
reading I want to read it and Mark it
out man it smells good oh it says on
sale December city to those who seem I
like that this is limited there's only
like 15 of these in the world or
something I'm serious but you are I need
them for my videos you don't need a
simple yeah I want to have a stack on
the table next to me to put them in the
videos can you sign this oh my god these
are mine why don't the Sinai own blood
so you're not gonna give me how do I
sign it and give it to you once i get
the hard covers that I put on video huh
just say yes oh yeah look at that that's
what
200 200 in police women pages inside hey
I love you okay I love you I'm corrected
through for a limited distribution you
can't buy this yeah so you have to get
you this is the limit edition should I
give her one I think I shall give her
one this is pretty special yeah you're
special to me you're more special
because you know this is pretty special
hmm it's still pretty special what are
you gonna do with it after december or
whenever get the cart covers I don't
know I'm gonna sign one to do one to my
wife I'll be getting the first one yes
sincerely of course easy okay thank you
from pinky promise pinky promise pinky
promise I'll picky province okay the sun
direct no idea the hard copy yeah well
might be December looks good this looks
good guys I'm excited how I said I'm
excited yet right now all we've seen is
like these binders right you guys have
seen the binders I've shown in other
videos just binders and here is like an
actual book belongs in a bookshop we're
other books honor so say we got a bad
guy I'm going to sink now that was
they smell did not smell like amazing I
kiss kidding me oh yeah that's smells
like victory have a good night have a
good night have a good night thank you
guys are joining me you can thank Nina
for making me make this video right now
because I wanted to wait when you
excited after we did it good continue to
believe or whatever your one word is
believed or anything don't you see maybe
we use them as bonuses for something
guess I've ideas for bonuses but we can
use this for you can comment something
up I don't need to keep all this gotta
keep a couple I might give under my wife
haha European
I'll just sign them all dear Evan thank
you so much for in this book sincerely
Evan plate believe i believe go gamma no
it's off Nina's first learning yeah
that's it hey Lena's first song ever
commenting arms begin there that's okay
you know how beginners start at the
beginning everybody starts at the
beginning that's good